good afternoon i'm lieutenant ray
spencer i'm the homicide lieutenant with
the las vegas metropolitan police
department
i'm out here this evening to brief you
on a critical
injury investigation that homicide has
taken over
the investigation the details that i
have right now are very preliminary
but at around 2 30 this afternoon
there were two vehicles that were
involved in a road rage incident
there's a green jeep that was traveling
eastbound on desert inn
at some point the driver of a green
suburban cut that vehicle off
when that occurred the driver of the
jeep honked his horn
at the suburban a passenger inside the
suburban
exited the car and walked back to the
jeep and at some point
threw a can we believe a can of beer at
the
front of the jeep
then the driver of the jeep who is a
white male in his mid 70s
exited the jeep and confronted the
driver of the
or one of the passengers in the suburban
there is some altercation that takes
place in front of the jeep
the altercation then moves to the front
of the suburban
the one of the passengers in the
suburban then gets back into the
suburban
however the driver of the jeep is still
standing in front of the
suburban the driver of the suburban
drives off and runs over the
white male in his 70s the
suburban then makes a u-turn drives over
the median
and drives westbound on desert inn
fleeing the scene
a patrol officer is in the area at the
time this is
occurring is flagged down by a witness
and is able to make a
car stop on the suburban there are two
people in custody that were inside the
suburban we are still there's a lot of
it's a dynamic incident at this point we
still have a lot of people to interview
and we're still in the process of
processing the crime scene
i urge any witnesses who may have been
in the area
who observed the incident please reach
out to crime stoppers you can do
anonymous tip through crime stoppers so
again i'll take a couple questions but
it's very early on in the investigation
is any impairment suspected of any of
the drivers
no there's no impairment suspected in
either of the drivers
so the the victim was standing in front
of the
suburban the driver of the suburban
accelerated ran over the victim then
made a u-turn and fled the area
so he was standing directly in front of
the car when the driver took off
that is correct the shoes that you're
looking at do belong to the victim
i guess just give some tips about road
rage incidents and what people
should do should avoid should not do so
again never get out of your vehicle in a
road rage incident if there's an
incident where someone honks their horn
at you
or anything involving road rage just
turn
make a right turn go the opposite
direction that way you're not putting
yourself in a situation that can quickly
escalate
you can also call three one one and
report the information
and that information will be broadcast
to officers yes sir
can you explain why in this situation
as a result of getting briefed on the
victim's injuries
we've taken over the investigation at
this point as a result of his injuries
he is currently in extremely critical
condition
roughly the people in the suburban what
are they facing at this point
well right now again it's still early on
in the investigation so
we're still determining the nature of
the charges but
as the homicide section we're out here
uh leading the investigation that would
kind of lead you in that direction
he's in critical condition at sunrise
hospital and you know
roughly how long you guys think the this
section of the di is going to be closed
i imagine we'll be out here for at least
another two to three hours
all right thank you guys yes
i don't right now so thank you